yes we're with irina and irina i guess
you do know the news that the youngster
has won the championship your thoughts
about her performance yeah well
congratulations to carissa she just had
an amazing tournament just won five
games in a row it was uh hard to keep up
with that
absolutely your game was a tough game
with talia she played a solid opening a
lot of space when you got the black
pieces it happens
yeah i mean i'm trying with the black
pieces you know i'm trying to play some
exciting openings but somehow i've had a
few of these moroxy bind structures that
have been hard to play for a win and i
mean you know i even felt like i was you
know on the easier side of this end game
today but still i mean it's a very solid
position for white and i just didn't see
any way to continue the game you made
this point about keeping up with her uh
you could have a great result and not
win the tournament looks like you're
having a great result now yeah like i
mean i'm it's not the worst you know u.s
championship i've ever played i mean
i've had some pretty good games i've
done well with the white pieces um you
know i think mainly it was you know the
slow start you know two out of four
was uh not so good after that it's
gotten better but still you know when
someone wins all their games and even if
you play decently you know you can't
always manage to do that so you know i
could kind of see the writing on the
wall when i saw her win against nazi i
was like okay you know um i guess this
is not my my tournament to win
you got one more game to go is the
motivation high oh it's high yes of
course i mean i'm going to do everything
i can in the last round to finish as
well as i can i know even if you can't
win you should still uh try to get the
best place that you can that's the
champion's attitude good luck tomorrow
uh we hope to see the best from you
thank you maurice yes indeed arena good
luck
to you and